- A hood pass is permission to
move in and around the hood.
I feel like I sorta got
one, but not a full one,
so today is all about
getting a full hood pass.
So I bring my boy BDot
from North Carolina,
and then I got my boy Martini,
pretty boy model from Jersey.
We hitted up one of my most
hoodest friends, Stevie J.
- Hey why you (beep)s
all huddled up
on the couch, touching
thighs and (beep)?
- I mean, I just didn't know
what the seat arrangement was,
I didn't know if another
homie was in the bathroom,
or gonna come out or
anything like that.
But listen, listen, break down
to them what a hood pass is.
- A hood pass is like this:
(beep) I'm vouching for
you (beep), you feel me?
Anything you do is a
representation of me.
Don't do no weird (beep),
don't do no buster (beep),
don't do no hook (beep),
and you'll be straight.
- How much is an
eighth around here?
- Man--
- You'll get your
ass whooped for that.
- That's real specific.
- What's your name again?
- B Dot.
- B Dot, and you got
chained that fast.
Bro, the B Dot, (beep) that
(beep) can get you shot, bro.
(all talking over each other)
- What's your governed name?
- Brian, Brian is my--
(talking over each other)
- What about Martini,
though, that's cool, right?
That name Martini bro?
- So you like getting
drunk and shit?
- I smoke, I'm not a drinker.
- Why the (beep)
you're named Martini?
- So your new name is Zig Zag.
- Zig Zag.
- Take that weak ass bandana
off your mother (beep) hat.
- He did say something.
- What's your name,
what is your name?
- Zig Zag.
- No, no, no, what is your name?
- Oh, my name is Shawn.
- Zig Zag, you gotta
say Zig Zag correctly.
You gotta be able to answer
it under pressure and duress.
- My name is Baseball,
anytime you say this
it's like a code word,
everything just kinda settles
like "oh, he know
the hummy, he cool."
But if you're in the area,
and you say the nickname,
and that nickname
doesn't register,
it can agitate some things.
- What if somebody
else has your nickname?
- Nobody else has my nickname.
- In all of the
hoods of Los Angeles?
- Because that's my nickname.
- So in a way, the
nickname is the pass.
Guys, I feel like we've
done put in our time,
we've heard y'all out,
we've digested it mentally,
we deserve our hood
passes, y'all agree?
That's a yes, perfect.
So now we've got Stevie
J and the hood pass.
We're doing everything I
dreamed of as an adjacent,
but now I'm having
my hood moment.
(rap music)
Mother (beep)ing donut
shop, Slauson Donuts.
(rap music)
Eating here, man, check
it out, what's up, my man?
- Can I get a glazed donut?
- Nah, you gotta be like,
what that glazed hitting for?
- That was good, James.
- What that glazed donut
hitting for, homie?
- Zig Zag, bring
your ass over here.
- Let me get a twist, a twist.
- And hey, guess what,
guess what, guess what,
guess what, guess
what, guess what.
- Don't do that, don't do that.
- Okay.
- Let me get two
swisters, a black
and mild, you got lighters?
- You want some noodles?
- Hey, blow it for me.
Never blow another man's
noodles, man, what the (beep)?
You're trying to
blow my noodles,
y'all see him tring
to blow my noodles?
(rap music)
- Don't touch my dice,
don't touch my dice.
- That's a violation that
could get you shot, bro.
- That should get me shot.
- That's the eighth time
you'd have got shot today.
(rap music)
- What does this mean?
- It don't matter, just do it.
- Do I get a do-over?
(rap music)
- We pull up to the Liquor Bank.
- Y'all hood now, we're here.
If you look around, everybody
here hood, including y'all.
He good, what's up, bro?
- The hood showed
up, and checked us.
Some random dudes just
start walking up to us.
He literally walked
into the scene,
and was like "Who are y'all?"
and that's when I knew, sketcho.
(talking over each other)
I had to literally just become
a black male talking
to a black male.
"Hey bro, (beep) Donald
Trump, I know, I know."
You know, we just had
to make a common ground
happening real
fast because I knew
that if I didn't say
the right things,
I might have to catch this fade.
For those who don't
know, that means
get knocked the (beep) out.
He gave us a hood pass earlier,
and a part of his hood
pass tour was coming here,
which we was doing comedically.
That brother looked
mad, but then
Stevie J had all the answers,
all the homeboys to
reference, all the streets.
- I'm Baseball
from (street name).
- Okay, for sure.
- If you're down, can you
just give my show a hood pass?
- Hey, it's your boy Mr.
YBMF, also known as King.
We don't crush on a stocker at
the world famous Liquor Bank.
Y'all already know
what it is, hood pass.
- I'm very much adjacent.
For a couple of hours,
I thought I was hood.
But then all that
happened, and I was like
"you know what, James, you're
adjacent as a mother (beep)."
(audience applause)